hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here in the garage of Team edge
with team edge say hi team edge
I'm not markiplier this isn't my group
it's a studio space we bought millions
of dollars for I'm sorry they were rich
they're now poor cuz they spent all the
money on this amazing elaborate set
anyway so we have this shot-caller here
and we're gonna be playing Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire and while we wear it we
should them skipping I don't know we
haven't decided the rules they made it
up we have here we have we have three
skips if you want to skip you get
shocked
you can only skip three times whoever
goes the longest makes the most money
we're not actually playing for money but
whoever get the farthest wins the game
[Laughter]
why is your hand so connected to your
nuts if you don't get these first few
questions I get to slap you - never an
idiot if you don't there's a lot of
rules
no question where do you have a shock on
your neck okay calm down okay probably
safe we don't know and a little kinky
huh okay
what piece of advice most often follows
if at first you don't succeed hey try
again B throw in the towel C file an
appeal do you give up
try again try again yeah question number
two which planet the Superman come from
a Krypton Krypton be okay
gingka question number three question
number three Brian he just made that
because I don't think he knew you
pressed it yeah
this means alright so he gets that one
to go ahead then he gets to skip it yeah
yeah no I'm just kidding oh yes if you
equation she did it if you want because
he'd shock you but these are the easy
ones yeah I don't want to use these my
skip on the easy one go which drug was
launched in the late 1990s with a cure
for impotence
what say it again which drug was lost in
the late 1990s as a cure for impotence
hey ivy profile you don't know this one
a ibuprofen B aspirin C viagra vigor
look out slow
the correct just wear the case we didn't
is that ok Brian you're up to you have
the possibility of getting what is that
$4,500 no that's question number 4 or
$500 question number 4 where does
napoleon bonaparte originate from a
woman d be Sardinia
see Sicily or a deep Corsica you can
skip it if you want city if you get this
wrong your turn us over I'll skip it
okay skip maybe I thought the [__] look
at me okay that's not very hard of a
shock okay turn it up in a bullfight who
kills the bull
hey the butcher be a volunteer let's see
the Matador Matador the public question
number five for $1,000 which chase piece
which chest piece nice nice
always stays on the same color squares a
night be Queen C King D bishop are you
going to want to take a skip on where
you gonna skip it he can hear one the
night I'm done right where do I end up
500 bucks 1000 thousand bucks
oh no no five hundred yeah
[Music]
it's the funniest thing but I'm not
laughing that this is the funniest video
okay mark the beach man that kid you
don't get this I get to punch you in the
face okay
on what day is American Independence Day
25th of December July 4th come on ok how
many sides is an isosceles triangle have
Marcia does this specific type of
triangle only said three three yes three
four three hundred dollars according to
the popular phrase don't bite the hand
that what feeds feeds you okay question
number four for five hundred dollars the
ability to see outside your central area
of focus is called what genius either
another so you don't have another
question how was Macaulay Culkin left at
home in 1990 his parents go on vacation
without him hey along be hungry see
grounded be injured alone I'm gonna
enjoy yeah wait what was the question
again
no he left home how has he left home
[Laughter]
question number six for $2,000 a car
with the International registration
where England Switzerland Spain Ireland
yes England are you smarter you smarter
okay just to clarify there are no fifth
graders being one at the end of this
okay no England or Ireland that's a good
level that's a no turning back it's a
good shot this guy's gonna point this
this out he turned it down to three
[Laughter]
dude on purpose no joke hey I wasn't
messing with you guys I legitimately
thought it wasn't on stop can't you just
do it right the first time
why did you the mess with HIV funny man
and make it all limp trying to be funny
man
but I'd be funny back huh hey funny man
over there ok restart shot them together
okay this question is probably the
dumbest question I've ever read in my
life and just read it yeah
what would you do with a burrito hey
where it could be eat it
see play it he drives it good I think
the burrito like an episode aren't you
in the DUIs I dare you process garage
curves I think you want to wear the
breather let me put in my mouth skip
that's what you do with breathers you
put it guys up and down it doesn't shock
no turns out he's correct question
number $2,200 show doesn't doesn't how
many milligrams who how many milligrams
in a gram a 1000 I'm American you still
this engineering major so we should know
this he's probably not film major dude
and you know this right oh yeah how many
grams is your camera I don't know bro
exactly how many millions
Graham a 1000 be 100 500 d 10/10 no
that's not a shark you shark - that's
yeah sure yeah it's a [__] yes it didn't
yes it did it was ok with Millie oh
you're done lost yeah
that's your turn it was a thousand but
there are a thousand million million is
a paladin Menil oh yeah the loading I
read it I think it's thousand I'm not
sure yeah the millisecond oh this is 23
its times three this is rigged
jeez how much you got one question track
oh good how is he home alone
oh yeah no answer Jess which of the
following is not gas nitrogen mercury
mercury nice nice man that was the first
really easy question but it's not it's
not what do I need to from what language
does the word alphabet come from
flattened Sanskrit Greek or French oh
that is question number two that's what
I'm saying you got the easy one Latin
Wow okay first of all I didn't you Latin
the Greek like one would think is the
root of all of it but Elsa though alpha
should have a shred of Greek alpha what
but no Greek alphabet but oh so you guys
that we have to determine who's laughing
wait what was your first three questions
doesn't matter if you like yours what do
you do with you know so your loser
either has to spin the wheel or get
shocked at the highest level so then you
will what's the weed on the wheel oh
this is the wheel of punishment wheel of
misfortune wheel of misfortune correct
that's my cash yeah all right okay the
loser not only has to get shocked but
know one of the other one of the alright
alright so ever answers it first right
is that what we're doing
yes okay reprise records was set up by
which singer after he stopped recording
with capital Bon Jovi Kurt Cobain Frank
Sinatra Bruce Springsteen I just say
it's not no I say it's not printing it
is Frank Sinatra Paper Scissors how
about that I really thought paper
scissors rock paper scissors
this is the worst thing ever
yeah you have no idea how painful is to
watch a play rockers do the same thing
no this is a fire firing his first time
doing that by the way all right off to
the backyard to throw 50 water balloons
at Mathias where you're gonna throw
water balloons this stuff Oh Marc is
gonna get shocked real quick
Oh because we promised at the beginning
we did you try that the plug that just
means doubling it oh my god oh you put
your fingers on it really good
apparently Marc doesn't know math
because plus two is not double you know
yeah like it was doubling cuz we were on
five and it went up to eight now is more
Oh
[Music]
punishment we're down here so anyway
thank you so much for watching if you
want to see another challenge that we
did we're gonna be doing the backwards
action challenge I don't even know how
that one goes
we didn't even know how this one was
gonna go so let us know if you enjoyed
it and thanks again everybody for
watching you'll see that video it's in
the link down in the description below
on our channel the thing that I always
do it was done he pussied out of the
neck aid so lovely
links in the description thanks again
for watching as always see you in the
next one bye